[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Doug is
in Milwaukee hi Doug welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi Dave and George it's a pleasure
and honor to speak with both of you you
too what's
up hey um just uh wanted to confirm what
I think you would say but I'm a
approaching 65 I still want to work past
my 65th birthday I recently became
unemployed so I'm job seeking um but I
have a small 401K from my last job only
about
25,000 I wondered if it would be wise to
cash that out and pay off Consumer Debt
of about
[Music]
20,000 um well obviously you're not
going to have penalty on it but you will
have taxes on
it um what concerns me is what that
leaves us with which is
nothing and you're 65 years
old yeah so
um we OB I mean obviously what you would
love to have is a big old pile of
savings and no debt right correct yeah
and so uh how how can we best get there
and then how do we use this money to do
that um I would prefer to leave it alone
almost as a symbolic act that I'm going
to add a bunch to my retirement as soon
as I can get Reemployment and clear this
20,000 mhm but in a worst case scenario
I would clear it I would use the money
and clear the debt but I I think you
need to have the mindset of I got to get
this debt cleared quickly so that I can
quickly add to my retirement Nest EG
because you need to be doing both
agreed agreed yeah so what were you
making before you got laid
off I was making about 60,000 okay doing
what uh it support okay all right cool
what kind of debt do you have have p uh
I have about a
um 15 or between 13 and 15,000 in credit
card debt and another uh 7,000 and a uh
uh no interest loan on some uh machine
Machinery my wife uses in her
job what does she
make uh she makes about 300 a month okay
$300 yeah $300 yes and what's the
Machinery because it sounds like this is
not going to Roi for
her uh it's uh basically highend sewing
machines yeah she's a seam Serv by trade
well it's it's there I mean it's not
worth anything now so
um we wouldn't make that investment
again 7,000 to create
300 um 300 is 3600 a year uh you need to
make a better return on that as a
seamstress or anything else in business
so um but that you're there now CU that
machine is not worth what you paid for
it so um now it's not because it's used
um yeah I I think you got an opportunity
as somebody that knows something about
it to do a lot of side hustles uh
freelance work as well as pick up some
jobs so I I just you know I want if I'm
in your shoes I want to create as much
income as I can create and knock this
20,000 out as fast as possible living on
a very very tight budget uh I'm going to
also ask her to to put the uh old sewing
machine in gear and let's do a lot more
than 300 a month let's try to get that
to 3,000 a month um and try to get some
income coming in so that we've got a
nest egg to retire on here uh but yeah
you know I do have a side or I did have
a side hustle I am getting some work
from now but I'm actually trying to cash
flow training for another uh another job
that I think I'd love more and it
shirt uh no what actually I'd like to
become a a Ramsey Financial coach okay
all right um I would not spend money on
that right now if I were you I'd love to
have you as a coach I'm not trying to
insult you I'm just saying I I would
rather you go and make some money right
now and get some of these other things
going before you spend money on
something like that I we we'd love to
have you don't misunderstand Doug I'm
not trying to be mean to you but um but
I also wouldn't be I'd be bit
hypocritical I'm like yeah give me a
bunch of money while you're broke and
you can get you know no I I uh
uh let's call that an encore career once
we clean this yeah let's put that as
something once you've got the got the
debt cleaned up you got some money going
into retirement and then go find the
money to go get the certification on
that I would do that but uh no I
wouldn't spend the money right now to go
uh in you know effectively into debt cuz
you're instead of paying it on debt
you're going to spend the money on that
so no I I couldn't do that for you I
wouldn't I wouldn't be consistent if I
suggested that even though I do believe
in our coaches and I and I'm again not
trying to be insulting to you